auch die abgeordneten des bundestages
können sich der zunehmenden tendenz zur
aufgeregten debatte nicht ganz entziehen
in der haushaltsdebatte des bundestages
war das thema klima der große renner vor
einem jahr noch hat man über
migrationspolitik gesprochen heute also
die welten rettung durch das klima die
kanzlerin fand große worte eingangs der
debatte und liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen es kommt jetzt darauf an wie
wir diese aufgabe eindruck ich ohne sie
so ein dass du doch die bundesregierung
dass ihr seid eine menschheits
herausforderung begreifen
die grünen sprachen selbstverständlich
über das klima deren
fraktionsvorsitzende göring eckardt
warnte zwar alle reden über das klima
aber dann nur um das selber auch zu tun
und ausgiebig in ihren reden zu machen
dass endlich gehandelt werden müsste
diese haushalt das was sie hier
vorgelegt haben und was dann irgendwie
noch beraten werden soll
das ist eine doppelte null nämlich kein
plan und kein geld das kann sich das
klima nicht leisten meine damen und
herren in meinem budget der koalition an
die grünen seien bereit zu gesprächen
sogar im bundestag zu verhandlungen
sagte sie über maßnahmen gegen den
klimawandel auch von spd seiten wurde
das thema hoch gehängt und zwar so dass
man den eindruck hatte
daran wird diese koalition nicht
scheitern der vorsitzende rolf mützenich
sagte das klima kabinett das in der
nächsten woche tagt müsse die weichen
stellen das klang nicht so als halte er
das für unmöglich unser ziel
sind investitionen in bereiche die bei
uns der verbesserung des klimas helfen
und gleichzeitig neue arbeitsplätze
schaffen nur wenn sich wirtschaft und
staat zu großen anstrengungen bekennen
kann die transformation für innovation
und beschäftigung auch gelingen eine
kleine ausnahme machte der fdp
vorsitzende christian lindner der zwar
nicht die bedeutung der klimapolitik
leugnete aber nach dem tödlichen unfall
in berlin zumindest eine kleine lanze
für die geländewagen die suvs brach und
sagte die einen sprechen über messer
männer und das inakzeptabel
aber auf der anderen seite dass man suvs
pauschal zu mord instrumenten macht
angesichts eines tödlichen unfalls in
berlin das ist an pietätlosigkeit
ebenfalls nicht zu erwarten
dafür könnte er sogar ein bisschen
beifall von der afd
apropos afd deren fraktionsvorsitzende
weidl hat sich erwartungsgemäß nicht auf
das thema klima konzentriert sondern
schon nach wenigen minuten versucht das
thema migration und flüchtlinge noch
einmal zurück zu rufen ins bewusstsein
aber das ist nicht wirklich gelungen das
war daneben letztes jahr
[Musik]
quietschen der frühere
bundesnachrichtendienst chef august
hanning spricht von mehr als zwei
millionen überwiegend jungen männern
dieser 2015 eingewandert sind und die
nächste welle steht schon vor der tür
die migrationspolitik hatte es vor einem
jahr noch geschafft die koalition und
auch die union an den rand des bruchs zu
bringen das immerhin kann man über die
klimapolitik sagen ist nicht der fall
dort sieht es so aus als wolle die
koalition tatsächlich gemeinsam handeln
und einen gemeinsamen weg zur lösung
finden am 20 september und natürlich
auch danach weil er viel im
gesetzgebungsverfahren erforderlich sind
also das spaltende für die koalition ist
immer hinten nicht mehr vorhanden
[Applaus]